okay
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast the title of this broadcast is
vitamin D supplementation in pregnant
women effects on preeclampsia and asthma
in the offspring my name is Gus Lawton
WA and I'm I will be presenting today
with my colleague dr. Scott Weiss we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots for
more information please visit lab roots
calm now we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcasts is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can in
the time allotted you can enlarge a
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems viewing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button on
the lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please PLEASE click on the C e
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would not like to share little
background information on myself and my
colleague dr. Weiss as I said before my
name is Gus Lawton WA I am a physician
at the Brigham and Women's Hospital and
an associate professor of medicine at
Harvard Medical School
I received my medical degree from the
University of Philippines and completed
a training program in internal medicine
pulmonary and critical care fellowship
and an additional research fellowship at
the Brigham and Women's Hospital
I am board certified in critical care
medicine and pulmonary disease my
research examines the way in which
environmental exposures and genetic
factors impact the development of asthma
in children and I'm currently
together with dr. Weiss studying the
impact of vitamin D on lung disease and
I'm the recipient of funding from the
National Institutes of Health my
co-presenter today is dr. Scott Weiss
Scott Weiss is a professor of medicine
at Harvard Medical School and the
director of personalized medicine at the
partners health care system
he's also co-leader of the systems
genetics and genomics unit and an
associate director of the chaning
division of network medicine at the
Brigham and Women's Hospital he Co leads
a 30 investigator 110 person research
group involved in examining the
environmental exposures and genetic risk
factors for the development of asthma
and COPD he is the author of over 800
peer-reviewed publications and has been
funded by the NIH for over 45 years so
we'll get started with a presentation
the first half of this talk I will
present our results from our vitamin D
trial called the vitamin D
supplementation and pregnancy or the
vitamin D antenatal asthma reduction
trial where we supplemented pregnant
women to see if we could prevent asthma
in the children we all know this is the
figure that we've seen in our medical
textbooks and physiology textbooks where
we see we know that vitamin D is is
produced on on sun exposure by seven
hydro cholesterol in the skin being
converted to vitamin D in the
circulation this then goes into the
liver goes through the liver and gets
hydroxylated to 25 hydroxy vitamin D
which is the major circulating
metabolite 25 hydroxy vitamin D in the
circulation then gets hydroxylated in
the liver to form the active hormone 125
dihydroxy vitamin d3
a half-life for vitamin D that we get in
the Sun or cholecalciferol is about four
days the half-life of vitamin 25 hydroxy
vitamin D is four weeks and the
half-life of 125 dihydroxy vitamin D is
about four hours so you can see the the
differences there in terms of half-life
now we know that classically we've been
taught that vitamin D works on bone
formation and the skeletal skeletal
system but over the past 10 to 20 years
we now know that there are non skeletal
effects of vitamin D and in fact vitamin
D is important for overall health and
survival of the human species and a lot
of animals so in this slide we have just
a summary of some of the known effects
of the known non skeletal effects of
vitamin D in particular for asthma
we know that vitamin D effects the
immune system and that's what's
important in asthma so shifting gears a
little bit to talk about vitamin D
deficiency and insufficiency vitamin D
insufficiency and deficiency is
prevalent worldwide it can be seen in
all countries especially countries that
are transitioning to a westernized
lifestyle as humans we evolved without
any clothes and producing vitamin D from
sun exposure and as we have progressed
we have cut out that that mode of
vitamin D production and we're very
dependent on our our intakes through
food or supplements and you see here in
this review article that infants are at
high at high risk for being vitamin D
deficient and also pregnant women and
lactating women are at very high risk
for developing vitamin D insufficiency
and deficient
and that's why we thought it was very
important to have a clinical trial to
then supplement women pregnant women to
then effect to see if we could affect
the outcomes in the children vitamin B
is the only nutrient that we know of
where there is good data that has shown
that vitamin D levels have decreased
over the years so this is a study done
in the Ann Haynes study which is a
national representative sample from the
US the black bars represent the
proportion of the population that had
sufficient vitamin D levels or at least
30 nano grams per ml in 1994 and the
gray bars represent the proportion of
subjects who then have adequate vitamin
D levels in 2001 to 2004 and you all can
see that there is a halving of the
proportion of the population in the US
that have sufficient vitamin D levels
and that's why we think it's a very
important nutrient to study let's now
look at how vitamin D can impact asthma
development so a little word about
asthma first asthma is a chronic complex
disease and by that I mean there are
many environmental factors that play
into it and also many genetic factors
there's not one gene that what is what
we call the asthma gene there are
actually many that can impact the
physiology of asthma development so
asthma classically is a an intermittent
disease that is characterized by
symptoms that come and go it is the
symptoms that characterized asthma are
shortness of breath and wheezing and you
can see in the diagram in the top left
that when you have exacerbations of
asthma
your Airways are constricted and your
you have a lot of airway inflammation
and you have muscle hypertrophy as this
goes along chronically there are many
cells and many tissues that are involved
in asthma pathogenesis and you can see
in the left lower lower quadrant that
there are many actually asthma is not
one disease but a syndrome composed of
multiple multiple exposures and multiple
presentations so it may seem simple
enough to think that vitamin D can
prevent this but in actuality because
vitamin D affects many tissues and many
cells in the body there's actually good
data to support its use in asthma both
in asthma prevention and asthma
treatment this is a paradigm of how
vitamin D can prevent asthma and allergy
prevention so with an adequate vitamin D
status that starts in utero in the womb
lung development begins at four weeks of
gestation and so vitamin D can affect
that early on and that could lead to
improve childhood and adult lung
function if you maintain vitamin D
status adequately throughout life and
vitamin D also affects the development
of the immune system it is actually a
balancer between the th1 and th2
responses and also a modulator of the
th17 response which are inflammatory
responses in asthma postnatally if you
have adequate vitamin D status it can
also improve your handling of
respiratory infections in early life we
now know that their data is strong that
children who develop repeated
respiratory infections in life go on to
are at risk for developing asthma later
and we feel there's data to support
turning off the inflammation once the
infection is is done and that will aid
in the prevention of asthma so we
propose our hypothesis in 2007 and after
that the number of reports in the
literature increased however a lot of
these reports were observational data
and there's a problem with observational
data because a lot of the times where
we're estimating vitamin D status
through intakes and that is done with
some precision some imprecision I'm
sorry other studies have looked at the
assessment of vitamin D status through
serum or plasma 25 hydroxy which I told
you earlier is the major circulating
form the problem with these studies is
that they have assessed vitamin B only
at one time point and we now know that
very well that vitamin D levels
fluctuate both throughout the season and
throughout life and so vitamin D is
widespread and sometimes it's very hard
to detect associations if most of the
populations have low levels so we
thought early on to answer this question
about this hypothesis that we needed
supplementation trials we were then able
to conduct the Vedic trial which is the
vitamin D antenatal asthma reduction
trial and this trial has a data
coordinating Center which dr. Weiss and
I co-lead in the Channing laboratory in
Boston and we recruited subjects in
three centers Boston Medical Center
Washington University in st. Louis and
Kaiser Permanente in San Diego the
hypothesis for this trial was whether
vitamin D supplementation and mother's
during pregnancy with a child at high
risk for asthma and allergies can
prevent the development of asthma and
allergies in the offspring we had
several inclusion and
exclusion criteria essentially the major
inclusion criteria was that we had to
have a high-risk cohort so therefore we
recruited mothers with a personal
history of asthma eczema or allergic
rhinitis or the fathers who had a
history of these allergies because of
practical considerations we were able to
recruit early as we were able to recruit
was between the ages gestational ages of
10 and 18 weeks and we limited the
mothers to age of 18 to 39 years we
excluded smokers and again because of
practical reasons we only included those
who were English or Spanish speakers we
had a bunch of exclusion criteria and
you can read this here essentially we
wanted to cut out anything that would
affect the outcomes or vitamin D what
you have here next is a summary of the
study design we targeted to recruit 870
women but we were able to actually
recruit 881 women we randomized them
then to the high-dose vitamin D arm
which is 4400 international units that
was the 400 in four thousand
international units of vitamin D plus
the four hundred that they got from the
prenatal vitamins and the placebo arm
wherein they were assured of getting 400
international units of vitamin D if they
took their prenatal vitamins we followed
the women monthly and we administered
questionnaires we monitored for vitamin
D toxicity and we drew blood both at
baseline and at 32 to 30 38 weeks and we
followed them through delivery where we
obtained cord blood measures after the
delivery we followed the infant and
child every three months through
questionnaires and we had yearly visits
for the child
you had to measure anthropometric
measures and blood draws on the child at
year one and year three the next table
is a summary of the baseline
characteristics and essentially just to
show you that the randomization worked
that there was equal distribution of the
baseline characteristics in either arm I
would like to point out that this trial
had a high rate of african-american
recruitment so about 44 percent of the
participants were African American and
based on asthma epidemiology and vitamin
D epidemiology we know that these are
the subjects that have a higher risk for
asthma and also a higher risk for
vitamin D deficiency and insufficiency
these are more of the baseline
characteristics and again just to show
you that the characteristics were
equally distributed the next slide shows
that the pregnancy and infant
characteristics by again by by treatment
group and the base the characteristics
of the infants were very similar in both
arms what we see here in the first row
is that you know the the baseline
characteristics in the mothers were the
baseline vitamin D levels in the mother
were the same in both arms but we saw a
high increase in like the third
trimester in the mothers on the
treatment arm and the cord blood levels
of the children who were born to mothers
sadistically significant higher vitamin
D levels one important aspect I think in
the trial were that there were no
serious adverse events attributed to the
treatment and so at least for these 800
women in the trial and the children who
were born we can say that the dose of
vitamin D that we used here was safe and
there were no adverse events I mentioned
earlier that asthma and recurrent wheeze
is a complex outcome and we define
you
here it's a multi-layer definition but
we think captured the early phenotype in
the children based on this definition
two hundred eighteen or twenty seven
point one percent of the eight hundred
and six children developed the outcome
there were fifty eight children where we
could not resolve the outcome but that
was equally distributed in each arm so
what we have here are the main results
of the effect of treatment on the
development of asthma and recurrent
wheeze by age three so what you see is
that the children born to the mothers in
the treatment arm which is the red curve
had lower incidence of asthma recurrent
wheeze by age three than those children
born to the mothers in the placebo arm
unfortunately the p-value was did not
reach significance despite the fact that
we had a relative reduction of 20% in
the incidence of asthma recurrent wheeze
in the children by age three however if
you look at the differences in rate at
age one and age two we can see that
there was a bigger difference at h1 and
h2 than and age three suggesting that
maybe the effect was stronger early on
and just to remind you about the the
design we did not supplement the
children postnatally and we could see
that the levels were decreasing after
birth and may have affected the outcome
the results of our of our clinical trial
however when we looked at a post hoc
analysis where we stratified the women
or the children by the third trimester
level the light blue arm is the group of
children born to mothers who were in the
4400 IU arm and who had high levels
vitamin-d suggesting that these were the
women that were adherent to the
treatment they were the ones that had
the lowest incidence of developing
asthma and and wheeze in the trial so
this suggested to us that not just the
treatment but the level was important
and later on we we now know that
nutrient trials are really different
from pharmacologic trials because all
potential subjects for the trial have
some baseline intake of the nutrient
thus there's really no real placebo
group as compared to a pharmacologic
trial where even those in the placebo
arm had baseline circulating vitamin D
levels and that also effects the
response to the treatment as you can see
here from the nutrient response curve
that Robert Haney published in 2014 and
so your your response to the increased
nutrient intake will depend on which
area of the curve you are on whether
you're initially deficient or initially
sufficient so when we did additional
analyses of our results we then looked
at the effect of supplementation on the
risk for asthma wheeze in the children
stratified by an initial maternal level
and that you can see when you look at
the placebo group that there was no real
effect of supplementation whether they
were initially high or initially low
sorry but when we look at the children
who were born to the mothers in the
treatment arm we can see that there is a
big effect modification by the by the
initial level in the mothers where you
can see that the mothers who started off
initially with higher level we were
we're starting to discuss the
limitations of
our trial I had mentioned that this was
a high-risk group of participants so
there may be some lower general
generalizability to the to the general
population we may have had lower power
than we anticipated and as I mentioned
earlier that the timing and dose of
supplementation may not have been
optimal to fully prevent asthma and
recurrent wheeze in the in the children
so adherence may also be an issue and we
think that maybe one dose may not fit
all women that maybe if you are coming
in with a lower level that you may need
a higher dose to make up for that and
also we did not we did not supplement
the children postnatally and we now know
that lung growth continues through
adulthood and the immune system is
plastic and is exposed to a lot of
environmental exposures postnatally so
we may not have captured that in
conclusion for this part of the talk
vitamin D deficiency is widespread I
think I've shown you data for that
pregnant and lactating women are at high
risk for deficiency and may affect the
risk of offspring for the disease our
data suggests that a dose in the range
of 4,000 IU per day during pregnancy is
safe and that our results are very
suggestive of an effect of prenatal
supplementation of vitamin D on the
development of asthma and recurrent
mieze in the children
I think our results can inform future
studies of the role of vitamin D in
asthma and allergy and we've learned a
lot of things based on this so with that
I think I will turn this now over to dr.
Weiss who will talk about the effect of
vitamin D on preeclampsia
okay thank you Gus
so in in the V guard study we the
initial grant did not include
preeclampsia as an outcome but we felt
very strongly based on data that was in
the literature that it was important for
us to collect information on
preeclampsia and then look at that as a
secondary outcome in in the trial so
just by way of disclosures I'm a paid
consultant to Illumina corporation as
gusts noted I've been funded by the NIH
for 41 years and I'm an unpaid
consultant to Novartis so this is a the
consort diagram for a preeclampsia it's
a little bit small and difficult to read
but as Gus actually showed you on one of
the earlier slides we had 38
preeclamptic patients in the treatment
arm and 37 in the placebo arm so there
was obviously no difference in
preeclampsia outcomes between the two
arms and in terms of exclusion there
exclusions they were the same pretty
much equal between the two arms of the
study I'm sorry so the the numbers here
on this slide are slightly different
from the numbers shown in the consort
diagram because the consort diagram
include included a women that didn't
they may have been labeled as
preeclampsia but didn't meet the
American College of obstetrics and
gynecology definition of preeclampsia so
these numbers here are slightly smaller
we ended up with a total of 67 ACOG
confirmed cases 33 in the treatment
group compared to 34 in the placebo
group and and that was clearly not
significant but within the treatment in
the plan the placebo control groups
there was a trend toward decreasing
occurrence of playa king kamsa it was
observed among the women who had a
sufficient vitamin D status at entry
into the trial and and that was a
statistically significant particularly
for the the the the the the early but
both early and late but particularly for
those women who had a high level both at
both time points so the pooled estimate
of the odds ratio in the intent to tree
population was not saying it was
significant when you stratified by these
levels this slide shows the multivariate
analysis first the univariate then the
second column is the multivariate
showing the effects and if you of the
various covariance and again adjusting
for these covariates and affect the
significant effect of vitamin D on
treatment outcomes when we modeled this
probability of preeclampsia as a
function of the vitamin d level so it's
probability of disease on the x axis and
vitamin d level on the y axis you can
see that we had no cases of preeclampsia
that occurred above a level of 38
nanograms per ml suggesting that the
risk was minimal at that level but as
you can see from this curve with the red
or pink confidence intervals the
confidence intervals are much wider for
these higher levels because we had fewer
subjects at that point in the trial so
there does seem to be a dose-response
effect it seems to level off at a level
of 38 but the number of subjects over 38
is relatively small
and so the conclusions from this part of
the trials is that the intent to treat
analysis was not significant it didn't
show anything but then when we
stratified by level of vitamin D both at
entry into the trial and at the 32 to 38
weeks at the end of the pregnancy we
found that women whose vitamin D levels
were greater greater than 30 nanograms
per ml had a decrease the occurrence of
preeclampsia when it was adjusted for
covariates such as age race center
treatment arm and body mass index and
the maximum and the minimal risk was at
a level of 38 nanograms per ml but we
went on to do some genomics on these
subjects and the the genomics is
described on this particular slide we
took blood from the women at entry into
the trial at 10 to 18 weeks of pregnancy
on average about 14 weeks and we used
the rank prod technique to identify
genes that were overexpressed in
peripheral blood related to vitamin D
which is on the left hand side and genes
that were related to preeclampsia on the
right hand slide and then we looked at
the overlap of those two sets of genes
and we found thirteen hundred and
twenty-three transcripts that both had a
relationship to vitamin D either up or
down regulation of vitamin D and up or
down regulated with regard to
preeclampsia and then we took that gene
set and tested it in a replication
population where we then came up with a
smaller number of genes that were not
just associated with vitamin D and
preeclampsia but we're also replicated
in a second population and so that
represents the 348 genes that are listed
in that bottom box on this slide
we then did pathway enrichment and look
for molecular interactions using this
set of genes where we used mapped the
gene expression onto the protein-protein
interaction network using human net and
looked for tissue specificity by looking
at gtex and other gene expression data
sets and we were able to find that 52
percent of the genes of our 30 348 genes
were actually also expressed in the
placenta and that 86 percent of our
genes could be mapped on to this
molecular interaction network or this
particular what we are calling the
preeclampsia module so we went on to
construct something called the largest
connected component of our module where
we were able to find a set of genes that
was connected one to the other
that was a subset of this 348 a larger
group and that module is depicted here
and so the outer circle in the lighter
colors is the 348 the inner circle in
the red circles and diamonds are the
largest connected component of this gene
expression module and on the right hand
side we list the pathways that were most
significantly associated with being a
member of this largest connected
component and as you can see immune
function it was amongst the highest
groupings in terms of pathways that was
identified in this module we then
subsequently found that both the vitamin
D pathway and the il-10 pathway could be
completely subsumed by and connected to
this largest connected component and
that's shown on this next slide where
the vitamin D pathway is in blue and the
il-10 pathway is in yellow within the
largest connected component so in
conclusion for the genomic section of
this analysis that we identified a gene
signature based on RNA in peripheral
blood of women at 10 to 18 weeks of
pregnancy that had predicted the
occurrence of preeclampsia at
subsequently in the pregnancy we also
found that both the vitamin D pathway
and the il-10 pathway were embedded in
this largest connected component and
that the largest connected component was
enriched for a variety of immune
pathways that one would think would be
related to preeclampsia so another
analysis that we did linking asthma and
the mother during pregnancy to
preeclampsia also strengthen vitamin D
also strengthens these connections so we
looked at both a physician diagnosed
asthma in the mother and how many months
of uncontrolled asthma that mother had
and whether the serum vitamin D level
was related to that uncontrolled asthma
and in the multivariate model on the
right hand side the next of the last and
the last column you can see that
uncontrolled asthma episodes were
associated with preeclampsia and that
the serum vitamin D was also related to
preeclampsia when one controlled for
those uncontrolled asthma episodes so if
you look at again the probability of
preeclampsia as a function of
uncontrolled asthma and the mother you
can see that there's this an increase in
rest
so that the more the greater the number
of uncontrolled months of asthma the
mother had the higher the risk of
preeclampsia and the mother during the
pregnancy and that this was also related
to vitamin D that again the the the
probability of preeclampsia shown on the
X asked axis and the biting the vitamin
D vitamin D level on the y axis and this
is adjusted for those asthma control
months shows the similar relationship to
what we saw before and that you see an
additional decrease of preeclampsia risk
by an average of 7% for a 10 unit
increase in early pregnancy a vitamin D
level so uncontrolled asthma and the
mother was associated with preeclampsia
risk the vitamin D level was linked to
both the uncontrolled asthma and the
mother and the preeclampsia risk and
vitamin D levels in the was the
connecting link between both
uncontrolled asthma and the mother and
preeclampsia risk and the mother and to
our knowledge this is the first time
that there's been a link between the
vitamin D and uncontrolled asthma and
preeclampsia and the mother and this
coupled with the gene expression that
occurs and antedates before the
occurrence of preeclampsia strongly
suggests that vitamin D is critical
factor in the development of both
preeclampsia and asthma control status
in the mother finally I just like to
acknowledge all the people that worked
on these projects is particularly
kumon Mirza Connie who's the fellow who
did these analyses and our group of
Obstetricians and Gynecologists who
helped us with the reviewing of the
charts and the asthma diagnosis as well
as my colleague dr. Lata Noah and dr.
Sharma who performed the network
analyses that I just showed you so right
so um I think the next the next part of
the presentation will be the question
and answer period so before we get
started on that
to remind our audience on how to submit
the questions we already have some here
but for those who haven't submitted you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and we'll try to answer as many
questions as we can so looking at the
questions here the first question is
does vitamin D supplementation and
pregnancy decrease the risk of having a
low birth weight infant so do you want
to answer that SOT yeah so the the
question is what is the effect of
vitamin D during pregnancy on birth
weight we're in the process of doing an
analysis of that in our cohort it's not
been completed yet it does appear as if
there are some effects of vitamin D on
birth weight but we haven't completed
the analysis yet and so it's probably
premature to get into too much detail
about that I will also say that we did
look at preterm birth and that was on
one of Gus's slides we we did see a more
preterm birth in the placebo
of the trial but it was not
statistically significant we had but if
you took out the preeclampsia cases the
number of preterm birth was very small
was only a total of 18 so we had
relatively limited power to look at that
outcome as well yeah so for that for to
answer that you would need a much bigger
trial which we weren't powered for the
next question is how good a view Latian
effect asthma and I'm not sure I mean in
terms of the parent and child I don't
think there is there is any relationship
that I know of within the same person
for example if a female has asthma would
violation effect asthma status I don't
think there's I'm not aware of any data
there also but I think in terms of the
monthly cycle I think there are you know
menstrual cycle there are there is
epidemiologic data that the menstrual
cycle can affect asthma where they could
be a worsening of asthma symptoms during
the menstrual cycle but other than that
I'm not aware of any of any studies for
that and and and and there is evidence
some from the Nurses Health Study but
some from other studies as well that
asthma in older women is definitely
related to exogenous estrogen you so
hormones both progestins and estrogen
can influence asthma control in women
but I think that Gus is right with
regard to ovulation per se we're unaware
of any data on that particularly the
next question is can a single supplement
they can single supplementation vitamin
D and combination calcium supplement and
vitamin D be better so I think the
question is asking whether vitamin D
versus vitamin D and calcium can better
reduce the risk of preeclampsia and
eclampsia than calcium calcium
supplementation in pregnancy and we
didn't test that in our trial but and
I'm not aware of any other trial that
has looked at that question either I
think that it you know if you go back to
the issue of vitamin D calcium and
asthma there's clearly no evidence that
the effects of vitamin D
are mediated by calcium on asthma so for
the asthma vitamin D relationship I
think we can say pretty conclusively
that this is absolutely has nothing to
do with calcium it's it's it's occurring
at levels that are above and beyond what
you would need for normal calcium
metabolism related to bones as far as
the preeclampsia relationship we're not
a we didn't test that and we're not
haven't really reviewed the literature
on that so we'd have to think about that
a little bit more so there was a
question on asking to explain the role
of vitamin D in asthma and I had a slide
that I had presented earlier and I
brought it up and hopefully you can see
that where the vitamin D has many
effects on many tissues in the body so
it has effects on the th1 th2 pathways
that you're aware are active in asthma
where it seems to control the switching
from th one - th - from a pH strip to a
more th one response
it also has effects on the on modulating
the th17 response which is a
pro-inflammatory response in asthma a
vitamin D has been shown to have effects
on lung growth and development and it
has effects on the mass of the smooth
muscle in the in the Airways so if you
have adequate vitamin D and you have
asthma you're at lower risk of
developing smooth muscle hypertrophy and
then you don't have as much as bad
bronchoconstriction and I also talked
about earlier the effect of vitamin D on
infections I think the data state seems
to show that vitamin D will not prevent
viral infections what it does is many of
can have an inflammatory State after we
have viral infections the virus is gone
but somehow our immune system is still
revved up and there are experimental
data that has shown that vitamin D can
turn off that exuberant inflammatory
response and I don't know if you want to
add anything more to that no no I think
the simple way to think about it is is
that there's two groups of effects one
or structural effects on the developing
lung
the others are effects on the immune
system the structural effects in the
lung there's more data for alveolar
ization in in animal models but we have
shown that the effects occur very very
early in lung development at the time of
branching morphogenesis so it's really
airway size smooth muscle size and lung
maturation and then as Gus said these
immune effects which I think in in the
broadest sense is really vitamin D
functions as a rheostat in in an
electrical analogy for the immune system
sort of damping down the unwanted noise
from antigens that the immune system
doesn't really want to respond to and
giving greater control to the T
regulatory cells over the inflammatory
response so I think it's basically those
two effects that are critical and you
know we think that it's generalizable
beyond asthma to other autoimmune
diseases we think that the effects may
be slightly different in preeclampsia
but but clearly immune mediated
predominantly there where there may be a
role for vitamin D actually in
implantation in the wall of the uterus
so the next question is a question about
how to rectify vitamin D deficiency in a
20 to 25 year old person who may be born
with vitamin D deficiency and again here
I think it would be actually vitamin D
supplementation and I would recommend
measuring the levels when you start
supplementation and to follow up maybe
every month for the first few months and
if you find that the patient is very
deficient you would obviously give
higher doses on the order of eight to
ten thousand international units per day
and then you you bring that down to
about two thousand to four thousand
depending on the levels that you achieve
and the data currently is that I think
you want to have a level of at least
thirty our study suggests that maybe
even a level of 38 to 40 may be optimal
and maybe even higher than that but I
think you're on the safe side to say
that at least thirty to thirty-five
would be a good target yeah I think I
think that the two points that Gus
emphasized and one is it's important to
know what the starting level is you know
because if they're somebody's very
deficient then you're not going to be
able to rectify that with just minor
degrees of supplementation so measuring
the level initially and then recognizing
that it is a fat-soluble vitamin so body
mass index plays a role here and
particularly as you become more body
mass index goes up and this is a
particular problem in the United States
the the fat reserve serves as a sink and
they will suck out vitamin D from the
serum or plasma the the the other final
point here which I think is a critical
one is that we tend to use serum vitamin
D level as the biomarker for sufficiency
but it's not really the level in the
peripheral blood that's the index of
sufficiency it's really what's in the
tissues because all of these immune
cells have the ability to make locally
make the 1/25 active form of the vitamin
if they're provided with enough 2508 d
to do that and and that relationship
which is one-to-one in a lean person
at sufficient levels becomes dissociated
as the BMI goes up and the level goes
down so we have a little less than 10
minutes so let's try to we have a 4 more
question so I think we'll be able to
finish this
the next question is asthma incidence is
high in areas of high trafficking with
high car car exhaust and air pollution
what's environment statistically
accounted for in the asthma studies we
did not look at it here in our trial but
there is data out there where they've
looked at a cohort of children and and
calculated the distance from a major
roadway which is a good proxy for the
amount of exposure to car exhaust and
air pollution and they found that the
children who had higher vitamin D levels
even if they lived closer to a major
roadway had decreased wheezing and
asthma symptoms than if they had lower
levels so we think vitamin D also has or
we know vitamin D also has antioxidant
properties which can abrogate some of
the effects of air pollution at least in
children and at least in their symptoms
we still have - there's still more
studies need to look at this more
carefully and then the next question is
some persons say that asthma is
genetically related and I'm gonna let
dr. Weiss answer this based on the
availability ability of vitamin D to
prevent asthma in offspring can this
claim be refuted so that's an excellent
question I think that you know one of
the things that we're starting to look
at in the video our trial now that we
have some genetic and genomic data is
what is the relationship between the
principal asthma locus and children
which is the 17q locus which transduces
the effects of environmental exposures
such as respiratory illness and smoking
in - in terms of the asthma risk and
well it's still or early
it does appear that the that there is a
relationship between vitamin D status
and this locust but if you have the risk
allele that risk is still an independent
risk factor independent of the of the
vitamin D even though there may be some
relationship between these these two
things asthma risk is genetically is not
conferred just by this locus HLA is also
a very important locus there are
probably 50 genes the 70 genes that have
been identified by a variety of genetic
Association studies that may be
important in in asthma and it's still
too early to say exactly how the vitamin
D finding relates to these genetic
results Thanks so the next question is
is calcium supplementation alone better
than vitamin D supplementation alone in
improving asthmatic patients and I think
it's been already shown that calcium is
not a treatment for for asthma and in
fact if you want to go back to the
studies that they did back in the 1930s
where they supplemented vitamin D and
the the thinking there was that calcium
probably had a role and they were trying
to drive up calcium levels in asthmatics
using vitamin D but they did not see an
effect of calcium levels in fact it was
the effect of the vitamin D
supplementation that alleviated the
asthma symptoms in those in those
patients so I think again we don't think
calcium per se has a role in asthma
treatment what we think vitamin D can
can help both in the prevention and in
the treatment of asthma patients
anything more to say and then I think we
have one last question and it says here
did you assess for any associations of
baby birthdate or season and vitamin D
levels in the asthma part of the study
to help answer any concerns for
pounding by seasonal changes in vitamin
D so that's an excellent question as I
mentioned earlier and as we know vitamin
D levels fluctuate during the season we
actually used the dose of four thousand
international units of vitamin D per day
because a previous study by dr. Hollis
and dr. Wagner showed that that was the
dose that took away any seasonal
fluctuations so when we look at our data
there's no seasonal fluctuation in
vitamin D levels in those who were born
in the children who were born in the
treatment arm and so we were able to
abrogate that the effect of season on
asthma development using using vitamin D
but that was a very good question but we
also again in in addition to that we
also monitored a UV light exposure and
have skin monitors and a pill counts in
addition to the vitamin D levels to
ensure that we have both an accurate
assessment of how much sun exposure
the children and the mothers had as well
as being able to look at the effect of
that sun exposure in the mother and and
its effect on her level so we have a lot
of information both on seasonality and
on sun exposure from the sun monitors
that we can potentially use in other
analyses but but there was no seasonal
variation in the mothers as Gus points
out at least in the treatment arm right
so I think that was the last question
I'd like to thank once again lab roots
for the chance to present do you have
any final comments okay so I think there
are no further questions we'd like to
thank again all the all the participants
and for sending in your your great
questions just a reminder that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through February 2017 you will
receive an email from
lab roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event and we hope to see you at
another webcast thank you very much